hey let's go bros my name is Sam so
Google came open-source with this thing
I don't know what it is but it's called
deep dream and it basically turns
pictures to LSD like I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is I don't really want to
know that that Bill Clinton but yeah
we're gonna chew we're gonna check it
out uh normally you'd have to like have
Python or I don't know some script I
don't I'm not a programmer I don't know
how to use it but there's web science
that lets you try them out for yourself
so we're gonna do just a dad alright
let's start off with this beautiful
picture of myself let's let the Dreaming
begin Baroness
okay I like how my eyebrows became eyes
my boobs what the [ __ ] that's disgusting
let's try this sexy sexy picture of mine
damn I look good wonderful why am i a
dog and why are there bulbs in my crotch
it looks like I have anal beads going up
there that's awesome freaking nightmare
generator I swear to God
come on Marcia okay you look great
alright remind me never to do LSD with
Marcia [ __ ] sake Oh what if we try
Edgar
what the [ __ ] is this ah for a chicken
oh oh and yeah look at this what the
[ __ ] is that what happens if you combine
a furry with LSD we're asking some
serious oh my god nice dammit why can i
download furry pictures [ __ ] sake I'm
scared I'm scared bros I'm scared it
became a job ha ha dreams came true now
what happens if you take some really
creepy [ __ ] like five nights at Freddy's
this is gonna be disgusting
what oh it's not too bad looking for a
generator man what happens if we take
the same picture and keep applying
are we going deeper
the [ __ ] half of the sheekha's right I
honestly Oh minecraft on Elysee why are
they dogs everywhere why oh my god
disgusting absolutely [ __ ] it with wait
a minute what's do you see it and hence
enhance enhance enhance what is it oh my
they get